[Music]
hello this is our livestream so we need
you to confirm that you can hear us we
need confirmation that you can hear us
and can see us oh oh what's happening
there we are
oh you know how we do everybody good we
know how we live stream we can't we
can't hear that's that's not you know
how we do this hello now they can hear
us can hear all right nobody else with
me now you can hear and see us this is
good all right that's it for today we
just wanted to make sure that was well
thanks for showing your support yes see
you guys soon
how's it going everyone look at all
these people here in the chat alright
cool cool cool cool hello della Lana
Lana Lana aren't you aren't you preggers
now I think I saw that when I was on our
real rainchecks Instagram aren't you
goodness aren't you pregnant if you are
not well let's just wait for you to
respond how many know if you're pregnant
alright I already got a pulled up and
everything J all right sweet okay well
let's kick this off then already I was
gone for the weekend and didn't really
have internet access for most of it I
was out in the forest sequoia national
park it was gorgeous beautiful I highly
recommend that every once in a while you
guys take a trip to go get away in the
forest even if it's for a day or
something like that god damn right we're
keeping it real right now always so well
let's see what we got here let's see
what you got here alright so some people
are already asking no a lady just asked
me okay all right sorry Lana
I'd sorry to assume I I thought you know
if I owed you a congratulations or not
it wasn't that I saw a photo and was
like oh Lana's pregnant I saw text
easy to offend in nowadays is it not
easy to offend yeah
Tilton camryn Damian Cedric Hitman
hustin Japeth Ethan Morgan Dalton Tanner
Vincent Chris hey Chris first time
seeing us live well I hope we disappoint
you
sincerely Vladimir thank Vladimir Putin
oh my god I've been looking to get in
contact with you I hear you can help me
out
hmm thank you so much since the start of
high school man were [ __ ] old we're
so [ __ ] all right guys well you're
the last one with long hair what's ups
do right the only one all right so uh
hey Britney Lange Oh Mike I love I love
the how are you you guys are so polite
it's so but you're so polite I can't get
over it good morning and it's almost
evening here Vanessa I'm glad to have
your first comment here we're not even
gonna talk about movie news we're just
gonna say hi Oh toxicology's Hey hi
what's going on Kimani
I like a chicken pot pie sure hit man a
two elderly gentleman indeed okay well
um I finally have gotten caught up on
this bat where we actually just shot a
reaction to the Batman footage of him on
the motorcycle stunt double on the
motors and I thought that was pretty
sweet we actually record a reaction to
new rockstars latest video for it and
keep a lookout for that one that was a
lot of fun to talk about
thanks Giancarlo for kicking us off here
with the thoughts in the Batman suit the
way I have these movie news catch up
live streams work is basically we we're
checking in on comments and then we just
sort of riff off whatever you guys are
talking about pretty much so what I
loved about the suit and this is
actually something we did not touch on
in the reaction so keep a lookout for
more of those thoughts tomorrow but now
that I think about it we didn't touch on
the fact that he didn't have a cape in
that Batman and the bat-cycle suit yeah
which I actually thought was very
fascinating to me because when you look
at the the red lighting of the one on
the camera test footage it looks like
the way they designed the suit because
they have that that collar going up
I thought they designed it in a
way where they could have an actual
practical cape there and thinking about
the CGI of putting on a cape on a dude
on a motorcycle in broad daylight
I feel like that'd be really rough and
the other thing we didn't talk about in
the upcoming reaction so get the
thoughts out now what's he doing dressed
up as Batman going around in a
motorcycle in broad daylight that's not
something you see every day you know so
what are your thoughts on that guys John
what are your thoughts on Batman outside
doing that and outside during the day I
hadn't thought about that particular
aspect oh the cape does intrigue me
partly because there has been talk about
there being perhaps more than one
iteration of the costume that we're
gonna see or something like that and
maybe Batman has the good sense to take
his cape off when he's about to ride
something that has a wheel directly
behind him that the cape could get
sucked into yeah I'm so I'm wondering if
maybe the Cape is a more functional
detail maybe he's going to use it for
flight sequences specifically but not
always have it I don't know I mean
Batman is pretty iconic with that cape
so yeah I'm curious they got someone in
here with someone in the chat saying it
could be a copycat Batman that's right
guys
clone Batman already during already to
Batman's or someone mirroring that's
true pointing out that it was raining
there I've always wanted to see like a
high-speed car chase or motorcycle chase
practical effect style and by the way
that's I love that suit is like seems
fully practical but that the cape will
the cape be on there will it be CGI does
he just wear that suit when he's going
to ride a motorcycle is that it does he
have a suit for every different kind of
V does he have one further for every bad
plane does he have one for when he's
working out does he have one for when
he's making love to Catwoman he has
branded that under her and yes there's a
branded Trojan bat condom as well this
is his Batman's condoms are they shaped
like a batwing are they black latex are
they clear like regular one because that
was the thing about the Batman
motorcycle that I thought was kind of
cheesy was the fact that it was it was
this new one
whatever the hood of it is called yes
shaped like a batwing little windshield
looks like bad ears that could stab you
and I like how into fashion is this
Bruce Wayne like I want to make sure my
motorcycle not only is efficient
proficient but it also looks like a
Batman motorcycle you know that's that's
another aspect that we're gonna have to
see evolve into the new age you know
because the last you know Batman we got
on the live screen was part of a bigger
ensemble so do we even get to see as
much of this side of his development so
here I do wonder cuz that is a harder
thing to pull off in a live-action more
serious environment is the hyper
stylized matching set of vehicles and
everything he has yeah well I found my
copy of Batman the long Halloween and I
also nightfall but then I've heard that
I should probably check out Batman
I think it's Batman zero and that one I
haven't read yet so my plan is I'm
trying to reread some comics before the
trailer comes out that way I can be look
who's look like this thing this looks
like that thing and then I sound
knowledgeable and then you guys like me
more and that's what this is all about
you could just go the Jeffrey Wright
route and read a compilation of like the
Golden Age like you know first year of
the Golden Age comics or whatever he
just tweeted out his research Batman
death in the family that's that's
another one that they keep recommending
here yeah so keep a lookout for more on
those thoughts tomorrow but what do you
guys think of the costume what do you
guys think of the Batman motorcycle do
you think it is smart to have pointy
edges facing you in case you follow this
stuff when he fell off I was like this
guy could easily stab himself in the
jugular all things go wrong it does not
look entirely practical very true very
true but did you hear the news John
about Kevin Feige almost getting almost
quitting someone here in the chat Uranus
a Batman hush is in the laboratory but
Kevin Feige almost quitting Marvel
because he wanted a woman to star in
films yes in a nutshell yes that wasn't
how
was pitched to me it was pitched to me
more than like it was a big risk for him
to pitch it and because some of the
biggest like shareholders were not on
that wavelength but uh but yeah I've I
was surprised to hear this tale
well it's inspiring to know that Kevin
Feige cares about diversity well let me
ask you guys in the chat do you think
women can star in films
are there any female starring films do
you think it's possible that a woman can
lead a fill what is do anybody what is a
woman anyway I mean are we even sure
they exist for real it's pretty honestly
I really loved hearing what Mark Ruffalo
was talking about when this because he
says right here Kevin wanted black
superheroes woman superheroes LGBTQ
superheroes he changed the whole Marvel
Universe we now have a gay superhero on
the way we have black superheroes female
superheroes ScarJo
and he was basically talking about how
that he had issues with the fact that
were no female superhero movies and he
did want more diversity in there and
it's pretty cool because a lot we never
truly know what's going on behind the
scenes of things but it was awesome to
know that Kevin Feige the creative head
of the MCU the Marvel producer that he
was championing for this he was fighting
for this and we and sometimes it's easy
to forget that even he has people he has
to answer to that he can't just say
let's do something and then they're
gonna do it at Disney because at the end
of the day Marvel's under Disney so it's
pretty neat that he fought for these
things and like I remember like with
Captain Marvel was coming out there were
people giving him a lot of credit for Oh
first female superhero and the MCU
people are like well Wonder Woman
already did it but before Wonder Woman
ever came out it's really awesome know
that Kevin fight he was actually
fighting for this so hurray for white
men yeah one it was also an interesting
piece of respect that pitch meeting joke
it all starts up here with house white
but yeah it surprised me to know that
Kevin Feige would be in a position to
walk into a meeting like if I see you
tomorrow I've still got my job yeah and
to hear that yeah he wasn't as confident
in his ability to drive
that decision through and stuff like
that like it does kind of remind you
just how far we've come and just how uh
you know it's like the change doesn't
happen at the top of the mainstream but
the change does reach its way there and
then eventually the top of the
mainstream helps to legitimize it and so
uh yeah it's I'm happy to know that
Kevin Feige has been out there fighting
the good fight I love how we moved on to
this Kevin Feige talk and people are
still talking about the pack condoms I
hope this catches on comments-section of
ours you know I really hope that condoms
becomes the the next I want to be known
for that I want to be known for the guy
who championed back condoms Kevin Feige
can have whatever he's done the legacy
he's created at Marvel Studios I want to
be known as the guy who first went on
the internet and said we need back
condoms a real thing damn you've got
nipple chills and that condom I mean
those are the only two things a man in
LA could really ask for Humphrey I know
I mean if you've got a bad condom on
chances are you are having nipple chills
as you speak
hashtag Dyke condoms that's what I want
to say that condoms get a tattoo across
your knuckles alright guys well those
are them two main things you want to
talk about now we're just gonna go to
the chat and see y'all gotta say I mean
there's been a lot of set photos
dropping like in the past week or two I
mean not only just the Batman stuff an
ache they also put out a picture of like
a victim that people were speculating
maybe like a Riddler victim but they're
also a bunch of photos out from the
venom to set changing up Woody
Harrelson's hairstyle after one freaked
yeah via post-credits Andy Serkis was
like that's the first thing we gotta fix
this and I'm the mocap guy you want me
to like perfect the whole symbiote thing
would venom and carnage but no no no no
let's first start with the hair dude
that Woody Harrelson has got going on
but Tom Hardy was posting photos I think
they were just taking down Tom Hardy was
posting set photos of I think it was him
in Woody Harrelson literally went on my
trip I would have internet for like a
second I pull something up I start
looking at it and then instantly my
internet would die on me and then I lose
all connection so but I don't know
something about that fact of especially
an actor like Tom
sharing that kind of in for showing
those kind of photos just wanting to let
that love out there for what they're
working on yeah that instills a lot of
faith for me and for what's coming just
because it's Tom Hardy and he seems like
a very particular kind of guy he doesn't
seem like the kind of guy to do that on
a set either this doesn't strike me as
that kind of dude well it's weird
because yeah it seems like especially
this next one has become his BAE because
didn't even like work on the story and
the script and everything like he's
really taking this project on as his own
little baby oh wow I could already see
that people are mad that Kevin fight you
wanted to focus on diversity we need
more white dude we're the white male
heroes where are they where are the
straight white here well that's the
funny thing is like some people think it
feels forced but in a certain way you do
kind of have to push it in order for it
to just be a normal thing there there
will be a period where it feels for in
the midst of it and and in within that
fear what of a tale a spotlight goes on
it so I think sometimes we misconstrue
forced for spotlight honestly sometimes
it is forced but sometimes I think is
just a spotlight on it yeah it's a combo
it's like it's it's a very very highly
discussed highly relevant topic and yeah
you'll see every version of that in
between which is why we get a lot of
these movies that have very ham-fisted
diversity plays or will have these other
ones that are surprising and subtle and
do a good job with it oh yeah ultimately
it's just about how well you handle so
uh did I hear this correctly briefly
when I was looking through the chat that
Harvey Y scene was found guilty uh not
of his like some of his like more
criminal allegations but of the you know
assault sexual assault allegations yes I
believe at least two he was convicted so
what's happening she's going to jail I
don't know what's gonna happen - Harvey
I sure hope so
I actually I haven't heard what the the
full on you know sentencing is other
than that guilty verdict and yeah some
of his like uh other crimes and
misdemeanors you know were acquitted but
yeah the the they at least got him where
her facing twenty five years Oh twenty
five years that's good that's not enough
go put him away for
as long as you can't know and that kind
of guy with that much money oh he can
find a way to buy his way out of that
yeah well you know maybe he can borrow a
cross plane I trust the legal system yes
yeah it's a totally been great yeah
don't worry he will also not kill
himself in a jail cell so she's stressed
oh well alright for the gallows for the
back to the back condoms guys you
excited from okay so guys catches up on
some more movie news here you guys helps
you guys help navigate the way this
conversation goes down know what else do
you guys got did you all hear about the
the coronavirus shutting down delaying
Mission Impossible sevens shoot what the
hell and the Sonic the Hedgehog release
in China [ __ ] coronavirus yeah and
ruining every it's ruining box office
and now they won't even produce the back
condoms because they're all infected
with corona virus like okay alright I
hear it's pretty bad what's going on
with the corona virus or I've heard some
things about it but what I mainly hear
is that there are movies like no time to
die not having a premiere in China Wow
[ __ ] Wow might as well do it anyway
what's more important than stories
what's more important than movies yeah
looking out for your health and China
just go over there people are much more
[ __ ] and goes there are always be
more people no I mean it's smart I feel
like some people it's weird seeing all
these like headlines of people getting
uh you know shine light on movie
cancelled due to coronavirus this
release cancer to clarify sir whose
movies say in box-office hits box-office
declines in stuff because of the corona
virus but [ __ ] man it's a goddamn corona
virus you know taking care of people's
health and safety comes first before
anything else so the other daisies are
just movies well that's the thing too is
I don't think they actually stopped the
production for the safety of the crew
it's so that they could change the plot
to be about Tom Cruise eradicating
coronavirus yeah and so they had to make
it ripped out of the headline hot takes
yeah I want someone to take a
compilation edit a compilation of all my
sarcastic comments
and and and push an agenda that I am
just totally not for the people I'm
sexist in reupload that supercut as like
Greg Alba being authentic yeah some kind
of a Greg Alba expose just real I am I'm
pushing this I will support this and I
will react to right now but yeah you
wouldn't be hours long it's just routine
you've heard that what I find in knowing
about the corona I mean there's a lot of
annoying things about it what I find
what I find annoying and silly is how
some people are just assuming that there
are things of like people are people
there's like racism that is formed from
this and I think that's the stupidest
thing in the world that racism is form
from this like Asian people are getting
like people don't get around me the
person's Asian might have coronavirus
that's not how the [ __ ] coronavirus
works goddamnit
and yeah current a virus also on Costa
Mesa see of Jesus Christ it's an
ethnically transmitted disease yeah oh
yeah it's not some genetic disease you
inherited runs to the bloodline of the
Chinese P that's not how it works I feel
like every time this happens we need to
go back and be like okay well what are
some pandemics that came from right here
so that we can keep ourselves in check
and remember that you know germs pop up
all over the world and mutate all over
the world it's goddamn you know
maybe venom 2 will do some type of
commentary on it mmm
I heard some weird joke at the showdown
I won't say which competitor said it Oh
but as it was a racist joke ah damn I
forget it maybe someone in the comments
can like fill it in or John can
something about something about Vin
Diesel and Coronas and I really wish I
did know he set it off camera that's why
I don't want to say yo you hear a lot of
surprising things off-camera
Coronas my friends let's give a
shout-out to Chris alas thank you Chris
blasts what wait a minute wait a minute
or splat where's the vlog speaker where
is it wait a minute its Pattinson Chris
blast thank you for the super chat buddy
you spelled it wrong though okay you
would have gotten points deducted in the
Schmo down which Bob where did you guys
finish Motel match we might have done
well perhaps check the results yourself
well Christopher what I would say to
that is Andy Serkis on directing venom I
think people need a kind of what's the
word what's the phrase I'm looking
forward to a hot temper your
expectations a little bit because Andy
Serkis while I think is a phenomenal and
underrated actor quite and I think to
capture something that involves mocap
effects perfect choice but he hasn't
directed a film yet before venom - that
is generally received to be like a damn
good movie you know what I mean like I'm
sure he's done he's done movies that
people have liked or I've been ok about
I'm sure some people even love them I'll
talk about general consensus from
audiences and critics so with that in
mind it's easy to get excited at the
thought of Andy Serkis
I know who Andy Serkis is and the work
he's done but in terms of directing I'm
sure he'll do his absolute best I feel
like he would absolutely do something
completely different than what Ruben
Fleischer did because Ruben Fleischer
has a very specific kind of style to his
movies I I've just I just think it's
smart it'd be wise to kind of you know
not get to express you John whoa what
happened I don't know didn't know know
to not get too excited about that idea
you see Chris Vince loves the Mowgli
film some people OTT of people really
didn't love that Mowgli film and it all
depends also objective I'm just saying
when you're dealing with these
comic-book movie properties it's better
to have someone on them I don't know if
it's better usually your safest bet is
to have someone on board
who has turned out a couple of films
already that people really do like you
think because you're dealing with a huge
[ __ ] property that's gonna be
critiqued by the masses and stuff but
then again the venom open up to terrible
reviews and it still made close to a
billion dollars and I think audiences
really did love it yeah it's absolutely
true I mean I feel like that was the
official film that year of like everyone
agreeing that this is objectively a
funky movie but is so enjoyable and yeah
I mean I agree I would say temper your
expectations although in this situation
I feel like I'm generally leaning
towards tempered optimistic just because
you know better certainly left a lot of
room for improvement on the you know
technical filmmaking you know story
structuring side and whatnot and you
know this I think is a nice pairing
because this is a popcorn blockbuster
the stakes to be as like heavy and and
imbued with gravitas are not as high and
so I feel like somebody with any
circuses skills can probably lock in
have a good time bring some creative
flair and and yeah I'm rooting for him
and I and I feel like this ought to go
at least decently no it's sure I mean
hey people are asking about is is Greg
as cultured as John the answer is no all
right John is significantly more culture
than me in every aspect I want everyone
to know that right now I want everyone
to be aware that Greg taught me all the
culture I know hey hey we got a super we
do have a super toy Oh Thank You Britney
didn't even ask a question Britney throw
a question down here so that way we can
honor your super Chad oh my god there it
is
oh where is it there right there she's
where names right there
have you guys seen parasite and what are
your thoughts of the movie Harris I
absolutely deserve to win Best Picture
hundred percent stand by it I think it's
better than Joker so ha ha take that
Joker now you now your money means
nothing and Joaquin Phoenix now means
nothing because I said parasites a
better movie did you see that guy's rant
did you see the guy
freaking out about like this best
pictures
whoa closer huh the under set my failed
private and lamina
I'm kidding whatever section I'm again
oh [ __ ] auntie signal who wants me okay
alright I'm with him I'm gonna make this
public again gets abused and kept relies
on my on my personality for looking like
a total [ __ ] and those are my
thoughts on Paris I have not éclairs the
first and last time I've seen him and
and that's the funny thing is that well
I do respect the film Joker I found his
rant to be especially facepalm II when
he's like films like Joker that cover
roughly the same thematic material but
to a less sophisticated degree like yeah
if I parasite was really terrific it's
it's really twisted and wild and it's
got a lot going on under the surface but
without sacrificing any of the stuff
that you're just going to writhe at and
squirm over and enjoy and yeah it's
really wild but it's also a genre piece
that I think really fires on also ders
is one of the films I saw last year that
had really exciting inspiring filmmaking
all around not just like an effective
engaging story etc so yeah much love for
the our site oh yeah I've seen Trump's
take on parasite I believe you said it
was the best movie of the year
hands down this is where we're gonna
work with North Korea yes yes I've seen
no he echoed exactly that guy stated I
was like Jesus Christ
Trump shut up Trump should go on Andi
signor that's where you just go on to
him because it's clear over all but it's
clear over time that he has movie
opinions and opinions about just like
celebrity culture in general whoa whoa
Chris Blass here John it's your turn
whereas from the past let's do it
well Chris as super-successful directors
yes with a three-picture deal what you
wanted to do is you want to put yourself
out there Chris drugs you want to
network all right you want to do cocaine
at the parties okay you want to make
sure that what you're doing is targeting
what's popular in culture what you don't
want to do is do your passions or I know
they don't make money you don't want to
adapt or direct the films that you are
passionate about what you want to do is
find out what's trending yeah what's
popular oh what women are popular let me
make a bunch of sexy bikini [ __ ]
kicking ass and films because that's
what yeah well I think the important
thing too is to question okay what is it
out there that everyone likes and how
can i play to that deal cuz that's how
you please the most people you know is
finding out what's gonna make everyone
happy you see this this is an [ __ ]
you put your nose in people's [ __ ]
all the way in the layman call that
brown-nosing and that is how you get
into directing my friend or or [ __ ]
that could also just be [ __ ] reaction
shots are very important don't forget
reaction shots never underestimate your
sound when I'm not I can't honestly tell
you what I mean like we like to direct
have we made sketches have we learned
great things
yes but are we Authority as we've been
asked or hired approached or sought to
film to direct no we have not the best I
can't actually tell you anything the
best tip is grab the nearest camera you
have and just start making little things
here and there and learn from trial and
error yes oh my god Lana well when are
you expecting Lana with the baby on the
way
yeah it is the baby going to be on one
division ooh what are you babies around
Wanda vision is the one I'm most excited
about you know I I thought I'd be most
excited for Loki but it really is Wanda
Wanda vision is the one I want to watch
the most and I really want to watch and
I haven't seen anything from it but I'm
really curious to see what they do is
she-hulk oh yeah cuz I'm [ __ ] woke
whoa I say the woman ones I say the
little bit ones
whoa culture honor a worse hour
what is a person a lot of people that
move her sock oh we need to get this guy
on the show yeah live stream with him
yeah I think want a vision of all the
shows we've seen teased Wanda visions
probably the most exciting although
conceptually speaking I'm still really
interested in whatever the what-if show
turns into but as for a swing for the
fences I see Hulk sounds rad I would
love to see that realize because that
seems like the most like okay they've
actually got to kind of figure this one
out again instead of just you know
pitching it in a new light I think what
we need to do is do 20 minutes of an
unlisted livestream and then go public
because I notice it usually takes about
20 minutes to really feel our energy in
group yeah saves us a while ten minutes
ago I really started feeling a lot of
energy next to livestream we'll do a
whole zip zap zop before we go on we'll
just play improv what's the name of that
dude who clown Don parasite can someone
give me as man please please find them
somebody please give me his name I want
to watch would you oh my god question B
Oh
here's the Sophie's Choice everybody
comments would you rather be Harvey
Weinstein or Roman Polanski's friend I
choose the night no thanks you tend
escalate on here that's true we usually
start off kind of here and then suddenly
we're way over here I don't know how
that happens
if if ya should Universal complete the
stupidity and thank you by the way Lana
again for that super you're so sweet
seriously save money for the baby okay
you look great wonderful you're you're a
real person got a great thumb now she is
a real person always always working out
or something
Jacob Mendes I like your new sure
Universal complete the stupidity they
took their franchises and crossover
jurassic role of fast and furious and
make a Cadillacs and dinosaurs moving
absolutely yes yeah I've been
championing for this for at least a
month I would love for Jurassic world in
Fast and Furious to crossover yes in a
weird way they're both about family they
are and you know nature taking its
course and they both started off with
hiding premises they got the high
concept hiding premises that stay
grounded that God just utterly
ridiculous and totally not believable so
yeah I think I would love to see that
imagine Chris Pratt interacting with
Tyrese Gibson yeah that's what I think
about it too like if the dinosaurs are
breaking out on - you know continent the
continental United States who can stop
them other than Dominic Toretto and the
family you know one last ride in
Jurassic world great tagline oh my god
they should make it see that's all you
need to do okay Chris boss was asking us
about how to get into movies and
directing all you need is a good pitch
that is true a good logo and I guarantee
you you take that pitch to them and go
one last ride in Jurassic world they're
gonna go done deal Bradley I will react
to Twin Peaks if everyone demands it so
they don't demand it so I'm gonna watch
it on my own
Robert storm what a great name I love
that name who is Thor Botox okay
pretty sure back on that's it as was the
end of the MoMA energy rose
good catch Thor in the second YouTube
was like [ __ ] this
video the monitor is this back to the
future musical a real thing or are you
messing with me right and Michael J Fox
is gonna start in it that is what I want
that's gonna be a flattering show
there's gonna be people on the side be
like oh no no he's just doing his thing
oh and then there was a moment of
silence put that in the compilation
compilation of all the serious moments
of the real rejects Britney's back
Britney where is it where's the fingers
they can't show people out there's
another thing it's by your water jug oh
I'm making a hand heart with a
microphone through it did you guys do
you guys follow me on Instagram
I surprised my girlfriend on her
birthday I work it's it's so humbling to
put that out there look how great a boy
you are how great of a boyfriend I do
that thoughtful thing I did that I
wanted to put out there to get some
views on in surprise
I'm gonna use my my YouTube Instagram
solely to document every time I give
something to homeless people just gonna
be like here all the selfless deeds I do
that I shouldn't be recognized for I
take pride in how humble I am Brittany
what is your daughter's name say hi to
her thank you so much too young
Cassie laying man lay huh little Ant Man
in the makin oh she wanted to wish us
both well happy Valentine's Day to your
seven year old daughter I hope that on
her Valentine's Day that you were
chaperoning and that the guy did not do
anything that was - inappropriate
seven-year-old boys can be handsy or
eight depending if she you know rounds
goes up you like that she date older
eight nine years old
you got to be safe about that a real
mother
wimzie strongly intact here three I love
watching this those eyes on the live
stream
they always fluctuate so much it's the
illuminance I people are joining they
like us people hate us the relief people
are joining her name is Madison hi
Madison
oh my god
Diego so true John Cena versus the rock
in in a fast and furious movie they got
to keep John Cena alive so they can have
him if I fight the rock in a fast and
furious movie that would be incredible
good good thing dude they need to do
okay so once the fast Jurassic crossover
is complete then in the next one they
can all take on Skynet and the John Cena
will then join that and then all be yes
for that in the Rock John Cena and Vin
Diesel can all take down Skynet which is
built you know some sort of you know
terminator built off dinosaurs really
quick Oh Tyler hey Tyler hey dudes love
you you're special you're so special you
look so wonderful Tyler out here you
better let me know mofo so we can go
grab an in-and-out 4x4 burger together
we'd love you to tell you know how much
I love you
you know how I send you [ __ ] all
time oh we got a relationship question
here from from Z Hunter's son way okay
we will we will go to the relationship
question but Tyler I love you thank you
so much how they sexy so awesome we will
answer your relationship question
because John is a relationship expert
that's what we need to turn this channel
into is love line with John and Greg is
this thing about Back to the Future
starring Tom Holland and Robert Downey
jr. real cuz [ __ ] that cuz ya know they
don't want that that should be Alison
else that should be an alternate
universe Rick and Morty or something and
no more that's the problem with is
because I'm part of the problem is I go
[ __ ] that don't want it and then I'm
gonna go watch it anyway
just know me what it that's where my
massive I'm not room at my masochistic
tendencies only come through and that
kind of movie viewing experience but
yeah that's about it
and what if at the end of the Batman it
turns out Robert Pattinson's Batman was
Clayface the whole time that would mean
matters just [ __ ] jerking off to the
rogue and I want this character here
this character here with this character
you I only agreed to do this Batman
movie some hot young white guy II
where's Taylor Lautner all right what's
this relationship advice questions Oh
John's the expert I used to like this
girl and now I'm dating another girl and
we're pretty intimate but I'm starting
to catch feels for the old girl well
that's a pickle tell them both if I
supposed to dinner see if you can get
them both in the bedroom and before you
know it you're a happy camper
you're dating two women at once if we
don't compromise your attention and then
you'll get jealous when they're doing
things together without you
and it's gonna get very confusing
because at first it was a turn-on but
now this polyamorous lifestyle has made
things all I don't wanna found that they
just like each other
yeah they're the odd man Alan and you
just want to be included so so the best
solution of that is to lead a double
life keep them both completely oblivious
to one another maybe get two phones if
you have to and you know really change
up the times of day and the places you
meet them you gotta you really this is
gonna take a lot of time and effort what
I would say is wear some back condoms
too while you're at yeah I mean honestly
dude it already fits that is a really
big pickle and I don't know if you're
starting to develop feelings for the old
girl I would examine yourself a little
bit because a how new is this new
relationship and are you just doing some
is this some kind of psychological thing
of like I know this other girl so you
know my feelings are more comfortable or
whatever or or you know is it because
you are you know having issues with
commit I don't know like search yourself
see why that is and if it's true that
you just really feel for that other girl
more I think you
well you can't dip one toe in the water
you got to be able to dip both feet in
there so if you can't make up your mind
on who to go with just jump on one just
jump on one and regret it later
your question Reviver or needs like a
friend to talk with you for like two
hours question we radio show there are
some great questions popping up here
somebody wants to know if we would
rather kiss each other or David Lynch
David let David Lynch feel like it'd be
a nightmare I would yeah we would be
scarier than kissing each other but it
would also be like way more out there
and interesting if you're offered to
play a DC supervillain who would you
like to be Steppenwolf
but without any CGI so just ciarán hinds
in the suit yeah I want to look like a
comic-con cosplayer yeah honestly either
scarecrow or Solomon Grundy
you can't play I'm to wait here to be
scarecrow way too lanky to be the
Scarecrow need a nice beefy role for me
I can cook all right guys we're gonna
log off in just a minute here see we get
us all 20 minutes where I have a lot of
steam that's on Suicide Squad 20 21 I
hated it it sucked James Gunn don't
believe the hype should stay it out of
Marvel you know what I heard what I
heard James Gunn this is actually a
guy's shift my tone a little bit James
Gunn's dog yeah word that it would that
he had to put it down the the pat-down
and they actually delayed shooting so he
can fly back to say goodbye to his dog
and so they could and that's pretty rare
especially for like for a pet he's had
this dog for years I saw like an
Instagram post he made and I think it's
pretty cool because I don't know how
much money you're losing when
shut down a set on a movie like this
it's not like alright we just won't pay
you know like you shut down a set on a
big movie like that this was scheduled
months in advance like I imagine you
lose money by the minute yeah on a
situation like that yeah I think it's
pretty neat how I think it's cool that
the the studio and the cast and everyone
was very supportive of him doing that
because I feel like you know a lot of
time they probably wouldn't give two
shits there and I think it was really
awesome that they were supportive of
that so those are my thoughts on Suicide
Squad
that's wonder honestly I do think that
like as much as it does I would be you
know mortified if I were the financier
losing money I do think that it is
admirable when people stop to do human
things and to you know have emotional
life stuff take the foreground because
that's what's truly that's all life
actually is so has was really important
principe say oh my god all that avatar
yeah dear look how sexy you look that's
him that's the real him that should be a
Renoir painting I tell you Hawaii that's
you look you look really sexy look kinda
buck angel that's like whenever a girl
in all the years I've been doing YouTube
whenever a girl like messages me on
social media and she's she's like half
naked and then you go to her page and
she's got like zero followers you know
that girl's real just like how I know
this is real this is the realest person
who has tipped us all day yeah I have to
say princess unicorn nipples we expect
to see you back here every livestream
especially when our live collaboration
with Chris Stockman the flip pick and
other movie review channels happens I
don't know how that would good you know
what's funny is I feel like flick pick
and I we actually message each other
once in a while on Twitter like you has
your biceps yeah we messaged each other
once in a while talk YouTube shop when
he had a strange okay show I went on it
what's up oh okay sorry my princess
unicorn nipples and yourself talking
back and forth and he had a screen
junkies show
now and then I went on his screen
junkies show when he had that briefly
and I feel like flick I'm surprised
really quick and I've never done a video
together I feel like Chris Tucker what's
weird is I love Chris Stockman's channel
i watch his reviews at least once a week
because it's usually when he has a video
i watch his reviews weekly actually I
just listened to his on word one today
and I get it's weird because I'm a big
fan of Chris Tuchman my favorite channel
not saying it was the best weather my
favorite is red letter media and I
really get the vibe neither one of them
would like us like the yeah I'm like not
I don't think they would I don't know
why I mean relative media is pretty
obvious why did probably like they
wouldn't like most of what we do
although if we were in a review
discussion I think you can hang yeah
it's like that's that's what tends to
happen with us
oh you're reactors and then we go on a
commentary show they're like they could
comments to be what it is that was like
a long delay of my for going back on
movie fights I mean a weed wheat JJ
would love John and yeah we did a who
who are you had red letter media yeah I
don't know I'm a big red you got me on
the show honestly if there's one
person's approval and youtubers approval
that I could that I would like it would
be them yeah is that sound hard every be
so hard to get their approval cuz you
never know who they like and who they
don't and I would be like yeah cuz I
even came across some video from I
stumble on in like a couple months ago
Chris suck when talking about how rather
tour media poked a joke at them and
Chris tongue was like they're my
favorite Channel he felt like like a
little hurt by it but then he like
connect with them they actually had no
issue with them oh they had no issue
with him so you know hoping that would
be but they like clown on reaction
channels and we've had our thumbnails
features every Star Wars related
reaction now man they're so freakin
well and I think so attempted it's bring
them up to Kristian harloff oh that's
the thing is I think you you I for us I
do think that it's important to have a
sense of humor about that because yeah
there's stuff on red letter media they
do that is directly ribbing and
satirizing stuff that we do yeah and I
think it's healthy to have that in the
atmosphere which episode of what am I on
red letter media you just got to go
watch their entire catalog find out no
we're like featured in like when they
just do a big scroll that kind of thing
iris I grew up with stuckness alright
guys well we could take princess unicorn
it pulls off the screen now they're part
of the channel now all right guys we're
gonna take off right now but thank you
guys so much for being here love I'm
gonna make some dinner and yes I can
cook someone asked me about that earlier
I'm actually a really good cuz he is
give it or not that's how I had lost
weight Chris blast thank you so much for
the super chats buddy Britney Lange lana
Pico Tyler Hague and princess unicorn
nipples guys these are fun we only do
these once in a while try to make it
weekly and then before you know we'll
get to a point where when we hop on
we're right in the groove ready kick ass
600 viewers ready to go yeah too much
Chad oh you missed the entire chat patch
alright guys we'll see you soon thank
you guys so much for being here to keep
a lookout for more uploads tomorrow
watch love glow how do your mother for
me John how do I on this top right of
the screen and broadcast no no don't
click that button click the start
broadcast on are you better name your
baby baby Greg I can do this all day
baby Craig